and i spend a lot of time with people
with addiction problems in vegas
and um and someone i really love died um
last summer
and one of the things that makes me so
crazy is in the research from my book
about this
i went to places where my friend tommy
and so many other people would have
lived and not died
so
portugal for example in the year 2000
portugal had one of the worst drug
problems in the whole world
one percent of the population was
addicted to heroin which is mind-blowing
right you could walk down the street one
in every 100 people
one percent okay staggering they were
top of the european league tables for 27
european countries at the time
top of all the league tables for death
right and overdose and addiction
and every year they tried our way more
the american way more they arrested more
people they imprisoned more people they
shamed more people and every year the
classic war on drugs that has failed
here in america exactly what's worked so
[ __ ] well hasn't it exactly and then
one day the prime minister and the
leader of the opposition um got together
and they were like look we can't carry
on like this what are we gonna do
so they decided to do something really
radical something no one had done
in more than 70 years since the global
war on drugs began they were like
should we ask some scientists what we
should do
so they set up a panel of scientists and
doctors led by an amazing man i got to
know in portugal named doctor
and they said to them you guys go away
figure out what would solve this problem
and we've agreed in advance with all the
political parties that will do whatever
you recommend so just took it out of
politics so the panel goes away they
look at all the evidence including rat
park the experiment we were just talking
about and the panel comes back and says
you're gonna think we're crazy but
here's what we're gonna do we're gonna
decriminalize all drugs from cannabis to
crack everything but and this is the
crucial next step we're gonna take all
the money we used to spend on [ __ ]
people up more shaming them imprisoning
them arresting them putting them on
trial and we're going to spend all that
money instead on helping them turn their
lives around and interestingly it wasn't
mostly what we think of as drug
treatment in the u.s they did a little
bit of residential rehab which has value
most of it was about getting people back
to work say you used to be a mechanic
you got an addiction problem they go to
a garage they say if you employ this guy
for a year
we'll pay half his wages the job the
goal was to say to every single person
with an addiction problem in portugal
we love you
we value you
we're on your side
we want you back and by the time i went
to portugal it was 13 years since this
had begun and the results were in best
research was done by the british journal
of criminology who don't have a dog in
this fight they found that they portugal
had gone from having the worst overdose
death in the european union to being
almost the bottom of the league table um
addiction was down by more than 50
percent um overdose deaths were down by
more than 80 percent there was just an
enormous transformation and one of the
ways you know it works so well
is that almost nobody in portugal wants
to go back i went and interviewed a guy
called schweil figuera who was the top
drug cop in portugal at the time of the
decriminalization and he said what loads
of people totally understandably say
when you say let's decriminalize all
drugs he said this is insane we'll have
a huge increase in children using drugs
this is a nightmare we can't do it
he said to me
everything i said would happen didn't
happen
and everything the other side said would
happen did and he said he felt really
ashamed when he looked back that he
realized he spent so many years
making people's lives worse when he
could have been helping them make their
lives better and this is something i saw
all over the world from uruguay to
switzerland to portugal when countries
move beyond the war on drugs first is
super controversial people think you're
[ __ ] insane and then people see the
results right switzerland legalized
heroin since then there have been more
than 15 years ago now since then there
have been zero heroin overdose deaths on
legal heroin none not one person right
more people have died of heroin
overdoses in this country since we
started talking then on legal heroin in
all the years they've had it now in
switzerland
all these con because they help people
right policies based on shame stigma and
punishment make addiction worse policies
based on love compassion and regulating
the market bringing the market away from
criminals and under control
massively reduce the problems they're
not a magic bullet they still have some
problems but but they work so much
better have you done any research on
what they've done in oregon
yeah yes this happened
decriminalized and legalized all drugs
yeah so the different street
decriminalization here in the united
states yeah so what is your research
shown on that so uh i'll just explain
the difference between decriminalization
legalization so decriminalization is
where you stop punishing users and
people with addiction problems but they
still have to go to armed criminals to
get their drugs
legalization is where you open up some
legal route for people to get their
drugs and that should be different for
every drug obviously no one wants there
to be a heroin island cvs that's not the
answer right
so
uh oregon can decriminalize
unfortunately they can't legalize
because um federal federal laws i mean
they have decriminalized they're
decriminalized
so oregon wasn't able to do what
portugal did
so tightly which is transfer the money
they used to spend but we know that the
outcomes in oregon are pretty promising
at the moment it's it's a very recent
change compared to portugal where it's
been in place for
17 years now but we but we know
everywhere else in the world that's done
it has had
radical improvements and and the truth
is you want to you want to say anything
in defense of the war on drugs you can
say one thing we gave it a fair shot we
did it for a hundred years we spent a
trillion dollars uh we imprisoned
millions of our own citizens we
destroyed whole neighboring countries or
close by countries like colombia and at
the end of all that
we can't even keep drugs out of our
prisons where we pay guards to walk
around the world perimeter the whole
time we aren't that strategy has been
tested to destruction there is no
country in the world that anyone can
point to where it has worked there are
loads of countries where policies based
on love and compassion and order and
regulation
work so at some point we've got to stop
copying the countries that have
disastrously failed and start copying
the places that have succeeded so if you
enjoyed this little short segment from
the podcast that we did here's another
short segment to watch or if you want to
see the entire podcast click over here
take care everybody bye-bye
[Music]